i'm curious like
obviously um we are in a weird situation
um you and i as people who rode very
hard for bernie sanders and and
and the ideals that he stood up for and
obviously was very frustrating
um two times in a row to kind of see the
dnc
like uh
it seemed like they really worked
against him um yeah
you know bernie he wrote he barney wrote
the forward to my book and when he wrote
it he was still running
and change which is out right now yeah
yeah and um
he says something in his forward and he
was thinking about something else
when he said this but what we have to
come to
understand is as much as the democratic
establishment two different times
conspired against bernie
it is it's on us to
make a survey of who is for us and who
is against us
and we have to out maneuver and outsmart
and out
organize them and in a lot of ways
um in retrospect after bernie was
was crushing it in the primaries
basically
and then south carolina happened and
yeah well it was not
you know he lost south carolina but
literally two days before that bernie
won
nevada in atlanta remember i remember
that yeah and caucus state that was a
caucus state right
it was a caucus state but then you know
bernie won california
typically the candidate that wins
california wins the nomination
and having won and competed in all of
the places bernie was always in first or
second
and and the democratic party basically
said listen
we need all of you to drop out we need
all of you to get behind joe biden
and we like need you to do it tomorrow
and so you saw amy klobuchar
mayor p beto and others all said okay
and uh it was too much to overcome
but but here's what bernie's talks about
in his forward man
is that instead of focusing on how they
walloped us in the future we have to
think how might something like that
happen
and how could we outflank and
outmaneuver how could we out organize
something like that and in a way uh i
don't think this is on bernie but i
think
that move kind of caught the campaign
flat-footed and you know
it's it's the media it's a lot of things
but at the end of the day
it's on us man if you know when if you
lose an election
it's on you you lost and uh i just now
in retrospect there are 20 things i wish
we had done differently to help this
campaign